allah you love a strong muslim if you
love a healthy muslim
because it helps me with it it helps
with confidence it helps with
you know the youth you know let's just
be real if when a scholar comes and he
looks like you know he looks hench and
he looks strong
when the youth look at him like damn
this guy is like you know i can relate
to this guy right let's be honest
but if on the other hand they're looking
at a sheikh who's had way too many
kebabs
you know whatever the case may be he
looks like he's not taking this
side of his life seriously their
lifestyle is not great in terms of you
know that's too much food man oh there's
not enough training whatever
so the point here is you know when you
see someone like that
like you know this is someone i could
look up to you know he's taking his
spiritual and physical gifts seriously
being on this podcast with you has been
one of the greatest blessings i can ever
imagine
honestly if only you knew if only you
knew
it's actually now it's forcing me now
not not to sound like a hypocrite and
put some of these things in action now
right because i'm thinking
what you've been doing for the past few
weeks or months you need to get back on
track man what's going on hanzo right
so this has been such like i could never
think enough
[Music]
[Music]
there was a guy who asked a chef he was
an atheist by the way how are you going
to feel if
you die and you find out that you know
there's no day of judgment there's no
heaven and how are you going to feel
and the chef answered i'm not going to
feel as bad as you would when you find
out there is
and at the end of the day i'm not saying
religion is fear-mongering islam is
fear-mongering but if you don't want to
have fear
of a love your creator and you want to
be logically sold on religion there's a
lot of intellectuals hamza zortzis
muhammad hijab
there's too many people subor ahmed too
many great scholars too many great
advocates of the truth too many great
cosmologists too many great physicists
too many great
even students of knowledge like rami
that are just out here doing
their due diligence open your eyes and
inshallah god willing
you are guided to see the truth but
allah does not change the condition of a
person until they change what's within
themselves
so if you guys don't change what's
within you you're not going to get an
allah's guidance
you're not going to get that
[Music]
welcome back to the realest podcast in
the dunya the three muslims
you guys asked for it we brought him
back hamza
andreas zortas salaam
changed uh since the weeks that we spoke
well you know time is relative so one
may
say it's been weeks but uh yeah in the
few minutes since we spoke
nothing much has changed apart from our
topic and all the
topics that we're going to be speaking
about right because today
we're going to be speaking about what
we're going to be speaking about we're
going to be speaking about
martial arts fitness stuff like that
right and there's a lot of philosophical
and spiritual values and lessons that we
can extract in those seconds
absolutely absolutely and you know
i always say sometimes training really
hard can be
a a good way of temporary temporarily
reducing the ego let me give you a full
experiment for this
so if you watch boxing right so
sometimes two guys two heavyweights
especially in the older days
you know say lennox lewis and mike tyson
they're at each other's throats they're
talking they're swearing that they're
being rude
but after 12 rounds of a good battering
they're hugging each other they're
kissing each other they're saying sorry
and why why that change now let's assume
the sincere that change happens is
because when you go through
a lot of physical stress
it can temporarily reduce the ego like i
remember
like so in ramadan i was i was going
through the
boxing training and
just before iftar or before it started i
would train like i would train as hard i
was training
any other time i missed time
me finishing training i believe and it
was like 20 minutes before if thought i
stopped 20 minutes before it started
when you're training high intensity it's
like madness now those 20 minutes
is a long time um and
you know all you care about is having
that water right
you don't care about who spoke about you
you don't talk you don't care about what
you look like how good you look how
right you are
you know you don't want to impose
yourself on anyone you just want that
water
right and even like if you go for a
really tough bag session like when up to
right like you do 12 rounds
make it 30 second rest in between make
sure it's
powerful rounds keep on moving head
movement and leg movement
continuously combinations three minute
rounds
times 12 30 second minute rest you're
finished or even if you add more
more to it no rest but in between the
one minute
space between the rounds do burpees yeah
and then go back on the bag
and you're finished by the 12th round
you're like soup
finished yeah in that situation
well you know sometimes be collapsed for
example doing something similar
and you know all i care about is just
getting my breath back
and getting some water and getting some
sugary drink or something
you don't care about who said what about
you you don't care about anything
so in those situations sometimes there
is
a kind of like i don't know i wouldn't
call it spirituality but
there is an existential or i don't know
psychological aspect where
you can use training to really connect
with people and that's why when you look
at the psychology of training
and you look at when people train
together especially when it's rugby or
soccer
or martial arts there's a little bit of
a brotherhood that goes on right
i don't know if you you know you notice
this yourself there's a bit this is kind
of like almost unwritten
social law that there's a type of
connection that you guys have
because you've seen yourselves in those
vulnerable moments where
there's not much ego left because you're
just completely finished and so much
physical stress um
and it's in those moments then you can
have really good conversations with
people because
it's the temporary reduction of the ego
so if you spot with someone for 12
rounds a very hard sparring session
you're both sitting on the
in the ring and you're leaning back on
the ropes and you're having a recovery
drink
that's the time to have a conversation
about something you know
because the your ego is lower and when
your ego is lower then
it's more easier for you to have
conversations about things that really
matter
um and yeah so training has that element
i don't know if you guys have
experienced that
oh yeah 100 100 so you're basically
telling us
he's telling everyone watching this to
go into the gym do a hard sparring
session
and then give that dollar to the person
when they're out of breath
just drinking that water drinking the
sugary drink
yeah why not why not yeah no right yeah
because
you're both finished and you could do in
such a natural way so if you are
training in
mma mixed martial arts or kickboxing or
whatever it is and you
and you have that relationship with them
that they trust you anyway because for
you to share
a sparring session with someone there's
going to be an element of trust
especially you've done it a few times
together
so when you when you go through that
then you you've totally physically
exhausted yourself
and then you can start talking about you
know look look man we're just finished
now and like
nothing matters apart from this war look
how weak we really are as human beings
right
look how contingent we are we're
dependent creatures right
and you know doesn't our contingency and
our dependency really cry out to the
fact that there is something
that is independent and necessarily
existing
what do you mean and then you could talk
about a particular argument for example
in a natural easy way
or you could just focus on you know some
chronic narratives on you know
the the human state and the human
situation that you know when we're very
haughty
we reject the truth and we think we have
this self-sufficiency right
because self-sufficiency and this
hotiness is a barrier to divine grace
and mercy
um and you know you could start talking
about those things so
it depends it has to be natural it has
to be part of the
relationship and the dynamic that you've
built with the person but what i'm
saying here is in the context of
training if you train very hard and
you're going through a sparring session
or a fitness session and you're both
just chilling now
that's actually a really good time to
talk about these things because your
ego's on the floor you don't care about
anything else above the water
right so that's the kind of you know
psychological dimension to training
there's also a spiritual one personally
as well
um the way i like to see
training hard is
i'd like to see training whether it's
weight training or martial arts or
boxing whatever the case will be
i like to see that you should
always try your utmost best from an
sand point of view what do what i mean
by this so
yes we know hassan means excellence and
we know from a spiritual perspective it
means that you're worshiping allah
um as if you can see him but although
you can't see him he sees you right so
this god consciousness is awareness
allah
is is is watching you right imagine you
know
your wife told you to wash the dishes
right and then
she had to go somewhere i don't know her
mom was ill or something
and then you're washing the dishes and
some of us would maybe you know a bit
lazy
won't do it properly but if she had a
camera in the kitchen
you were like doing it properly with
essen and making
scrubbing everything you know stuff like
that so when when you know someone's
watching or someone is always aware
then there's an element of consciousness
of that awareness that someone's aware
of you right
so uh we know there's that element to it
but what i mean here is from a fitness
and martial arts point of view is
ahsan of using
all of the gifts allah has given all of
the capacity and ability has it to its
maximum
i find it and this is connected to
shocker and gratitude i find it a sense
of ingratitude to allah
when someone doesn't try their best
because allah has given you these
abilities
and you don't even know where the limits
are
because you don't know the will of allah
because the will of allah is unknown in
this situation you could just keep on
trying to explore your limits
but every time you find one limit and
you you pass that limitation then
you realize actually it was a
self-imposed limitation
so the point here is we have abilities
we don't know
where that where their limits are when
if you
try to maximize your ability all the
time and maximize those skills and the
biggest
giving you all the time without imposing
a self-imposed limitation
because that is equivalent of saying i
know allah's will
about me no you don't allah knows about
his will
you don't know what you do or you can
just keep on trying your best so if you
don't maximize and try your best
i find it as a sense as i find it it
lacks exactly
like but it also lacks gratitude
that's how i see it so you know when
some people are going to the gym or
they're going for a sparring session and
just
not really focusing on on the phone all
the time and they're not
you know i'm like what's wrong with this
person allah has given this person
certain gifts
and talents and abilities maximize them
and do it from the perspective that this
is a form of gratitude to allah it's
also a form of
because you know allah is aware of you
and he knows
what your abilities are you don't know
where your limits are so therefore you
should try your best to try and maximize
them right
here's a thought experiment imagine
someone gave you
i don't know gave you like a gift and
you know you're opening the box in front
of him
and the gift has to be has to be used
say you're i don't know
what what kind of gif can we think about
here something that has to be used
to to its best to the best of its
ability
um i don't know i can't think of
something i say
well i wouldn't go there especially in
the muslim context
online talk about knives but yeah again
yeah actually it's a good example say
it's a knife yeah a knife cutting you
know
like cutting me and i've and that shows
where my mind is right
stuff but i'm only kidding
so he said more about me than anyone
else no um i'm just trying to be
cautious uh
yeah say we want to cut for example meat
right
this kurbani kurbani time is coming
right we want to cut the meat
that's just perfect because that hadith
is about slaughtering the animal as well
beautiful bro that's a beautiful
akbar amazing so uh
so someone buys you a knife for qurbani
yeah
and he gives you the knife and he gives
you the knife to you know the
life sharpener as well and he's watching
you
right and you open the box open the
knife open the knife sharpener
you throw the sharpeners away you turn
the knife the other way
the blunt side and you start trying to
sacrifice
the animal is that
using the knife to the best of his
ability
no is it a form of
gratitude towards the person who gave
you the gift no
same with your own capacities as a human
being especially in the context of
fighting martial arts training whatever
allah has given you this gift don't
throw the gift away
and he's always always aware of what
you're doing
don't throw the gift away and don't
misuse the gift
just like in the knife scenario where
you're just turning on the blunt side
that's the point so when you go into the
gym if you have that mindset
that could be a form of ibadah it could
be a form of worship because you're
saying to allah allah
i want to glorify you through the gifts
that you've given me
and i know you're aware that you've
given me these gifts and i'm going to
miss
i'm going to use them to the best of my
ability for a great objective which is
for me to be a strong muslim
and being a strong muslim is pleasing to
you
because it helps me to do more abadda
more worship
it helps me to protect my family to
protect those in need
to protect the oppressed to show a sense
of confidence
positive confidence and so on and so
forth
so all of this could be an act of
worship so if you have the right mindset
what i know
i've basically maybe complicated a
little bit but if you have the right
mindset
every single training session would be
phenomenal it would be better than
than than than training in front of like
a hundred thousand people or doing
sports in front of a hundred thousand
people
because uh you you know allah
subhanallah is always watching and he's
giving you these gifts you want to
maximize the gift of the best of its
ability
and you want to use them properly and
you want to do all of that for a greater
objective
which is you oh allah you love a strong
muslim
you love a healthy muslim because it
helps with
it helps with confidence it helps with
you know the youth you know
let's just be real if when a scholar
comes and he looks like you know
he looks hench and he looks strong when
the youth look at him
like damn this guy's like you know i can
relate to this guy
right let's be honest but if on the
other hand they're looking at a shaykh
who's had way too many kebabs
you know whatever the case may be he
looks like he's not taking this
side of his life seriously by the way
i'm saying this is generalities we can't
point fingers because everyone has the
social biological context a lot of
things are genetic whatever the case may
be
so i'll put that caveat aside but let's
be honest you know i've had dinners with
some of these people and
you know their lifestyle is not great in
terms of you know that's too much food
man oh there's not enough training
whatever
so the point here is you know when you
see someone like that
like you know this is someone i could
look up to you know he's taking his
spiritual and physical gifts seriously
you know
uh obviously not everyone has to look
like you know i don't know
hench or big or strong but someone who
has a sense of
confidence and it's not always about the
size it's not always about
um it's about the energy that comes out
because remember i don't people to
conflate you have to be big and muscly
no
it because when you are involved in
taking care of yourself spiritually and
physically
there is what you call a robe a sense of
an aura around you
that is a little bit different from
people who don't take
those aspects of their life seriously as
well it's not because remember i believe
ali or
had a bit of a pop belly obviously
that's totally different from being
obese or
out or overweight for sure but it's not
necessarily how you look
it's about you know are you taking and
prioritizing these things in a way that
is pleasing to allah subhanahu wata'ala
and other people may not even have the
time to be honest they may be busy in
elements and
and stuff like that um which is far more
important than going to the gym for sure
however just as a general point is if
you're going to engage in the stuff it
can be a great act of worship
based on what i've just said so yeah
yeah not to get too uh christian-y but a
perfect example
is like if someone wanted to get the
spiritual aspect of it since allah is
always watching
and it's almost kind of like the
equivalent of like
the father watching his son and the son
wanting to make his father proud
and obviously like i said i'm not
getting christian here because then you
know a lot of people say i see
that's jesus but nah nah
you probably understand what i'm saying
yeah yeah so look as i said i think the
previous podcast would
and with allah is the greatest example
lasik mr
um and this is not an analogy of course
you're just saying by greater reason
yeah so um but obviously when we do talk
about allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
we even when we use such examples we
should refrain away from the kind of fun
father-son scenario but i get the
underlying concept of what you're saying
absolutely
so you know allah is your creator and
you want to please your creator he
created you
so you want to please him right um and
he's giving you
certain gifts and you like fitness it's
your thing you like
martial arts so you want to basically
maximize the gifts has given you and use
them in the right way
and you in line with the great objective
which is you you allah you love a strong
muslim
and i'm doing this to to have the right
energy for your sake
to inspire people to show that islam has
a good way of life
and that we are confident people and and
also because i want to be able to
you know show that i can protect my
family and so on and so forth right
which is very important right especially
in the age of islamophobia
um because you know we have no choice
but to
look confident obviously we should never
seek
any kind of tribulation or any kind of
aggressive scenarios not at all you know
we're peaceful people
but you know if we we we have to be in a
certain spiritual and physical state
where
if something were to happen just by the
way that we look
it would be a barrier for people to uh
you know try and
trying to do something and that's why
you know um it's important you know you
had
really silly stories about you know
people's wives being attacked
or being you know that should be totally
unacceptable
and that should never ever happen um to
anyone
not just muslims but non-muslims as well
but you know specifically
you know the islamic tradition we honor
our women we are
the protectors of our women you know we
we have to be able to do that in a
confident way and you know
uh that's an act of worship too doing it
so you you're able to stand your ground
if necessary right
um yeah so just to repeat
use the gifts allah has given you to the
best of your ability
don't misuse them um and try and
maximize them as best as possible it's a
form of gratitude but also do it with
the great objective in mind which is
it's an act of worship because allah i
know you like a strong
strong person someone who takes care of
themselves
and i'm doing it for your sake in order
to
create a positive image about what it
means to be a muslim man
for example right or what it means to be
oh sorry and what it means to be a a
good human being that you know you're
strong taking care of yourself and you
have and it helps with your sense of
bravery we spoke about this last time
the process was the most brave and
that's a very key aspect of leadership
and let's be honest
bravery is a psychological thing but but
also the physical aspect helps it helps
with that very
bravery right so if you're confident
about yourself and your physical
abilities and your strengths and so on
and so forth
that helps with bravery and bravery is
one of the missing pillars of islamic
leadership
right um so bravery is important
um so all of these things so yeah so
have that
sign in your training and link it to
allah but
you have to also be very careful and
this is important for people listening
it's so easy to get involved in the
whole ego thing right
you know bodybuilding having that
six-pack looking good
now is that really for the sake of allah
i don't know man i don't know maybe if
your wife likes it then it's for the
sake of allah because
you know you know it's an act of worship
if your life wife wants something
about you to look in a certain way then
you should do it right
and likewise the other way around um but
you know usually when people put things
on instagram
stuff like that and their bodybuilders i
just find it a bit difficult to
appreciate that that is uh
purely within the islamic ethics of
things yeah
um it should be functional
and i would even say bodybuilding itself
is is not a great sport anyway
um to do weightlifting is good to be
strong
even maybe touch some size because there
is a correlation between weight and your
ability to punch
it's not a direct correlation because
you have middle weights you could punch
like heavy weights right because of the
technique
but there is that's why you have weight
classes right so weight is important as
well if you want to gain some muscle
mass for sure
but just to do it just to like make sure
your bicep is in like you know
perfect dimension with your tricep and
you know the the sides of your
pecs are coming out and off and yeah you
doing that for your wife no problem but
if you're doing it just for the sake of
vanity then i find bodybuilding a very
kind of uh
spiritually immature sport what is your
worst damage
chilling with you and she's like babe i
like the the the dad bod
the beer belly well stuck for a little
not the beer belly but the belly
you know i like that you know i find
that cute what would you say then
yeah well that's the good question well
i would say you should ask her that
before you got married
i don't know i don't know that well you
know yanny
if she doesn't like a six-pack then
don't have six-pack you could still be
fit and not have a six-pack
no problem i mean she's a wife man hey
this is more food
yeah yeah for sure i mean uh you know
we have to be careful of this so because
sometimes we always expect our sisters
to look in a certain way
but when you look at the brothers like
what the flip man what's wrong with you
i mean
you know you want you want you want like
a sister
like who's just like
and she looks like kohori from jannah
but you you look like you know as if you
just crawled out
of jahannam man some of us right like
but you know this is this is a form of
arrogance and you know what we said
about what it means to be a man in the
previous uh
the podcast we spoke about all these
psychological and
things and concerning ego and
forbearance and it's very egotistical to
always expect from our sisters and then
back and then when you look at the
brother you're like
come on man you need to fix up too you
need to you need to play your part you
know your wife has rights
you know the same right as you have you
know
the sense of physical pleasure and so on
and so on and so forth
your wife has that too and your wife
might not even say you know why because
our sisters have hayah
right they may not say it and they may
be suffering because and you just
you don't have that awareness because
you go you lack manliness right
because a true man wants to please his
wife
from that perspective that's what a true
man is it's not a one-way relationship
right i find it so unmanly unhuman man
unethical
to like gain from someone and not give
anything back
we should want to give back more than we
received
that's that's what a roman is to give
back more than you received
right and once you do that you would
enjoy the giving
more than the receiving but i'm not only
talking about this in in the context of
uh
marriage this is in life in general as
well um
anyway yeah so fitness is important so
what what what what fitness do you guys
do
mma yes
i was about to say uh before because i
we wanted to ask you about
more so the wing chun i want to know
more about that
but um what you said about bodybuilding
hits home
and i've spoken to rami about this but
um right now i weigh
154 pounds
which okay it's pretty light i'm not
gonna lie to you it's pretty light when
i was doing bodybuilding
before islam i was closing in on like
200 pounds
wow i was i was diesel like i had so
much weight on me
that my knees would hurt just from
walking around
i remember when i got i got into uh
into mma a little bit and it was
actually the muay thai
aspect and my friend was trying to show
me something he was trying to show me
the footwork
he's like bro you're so heavy like you
need to lose weight
and i remember like at 190 i just i
could barely move around
whereas i was just super heavy with my
footwork and then the moment that i like
dropped down like 154 i'm like
flying across the map bro yeah yeah
so there is there is a sweet spot but
everyone has a different sweet spot
like i i remember going down to like 82
kilos
i think my body weight was like six
percent body fat or something
yes it was i i just didn't i mean
i just didn't i wasn't comfortable it
was too too low
too low although that was my ideal
weight i think
before like from a medical perspective
yeah but i just felt
too low 82 kilos no way i just and i
looked really bad i looked like
you know may allah protect us like a
cancer victim or something man it was
terrible
i was very fast but you know if someone
charged at me i would have could
collapse or something yeah so everyone
has their own
own thing their own range and you just
have to find what that is
uh like if i was 155 i'll probably be
dead
i'll probably be dead now how would you
weigh right now my weight is
um i'm 105 kilos i think so i'm about
230 pounds i think or 220 pounds
at the moment how tall are you uh i
think i'm five
five eleven i think five ten and a half
five of the millions
so that's big uh yeah i was about to say
so
i'm in the stage of uh strength training
at the moment
so i've gone like you know a bit bigger
um
but my my view is to turn it around and
just basically cut down
and just to find that sweet spot again
um
because i needed that sense of strength
so like i'm nearly 41 so i'm going to be
41 in september
and at this age you need to start
focusing on
the muscle because your muscle would go
down eventually now you could keep a
very good
size and strength even up to age of 60
like you know people that train with
you know they're like what mid 50s or
something needy and they're
well i used to train with them and
they're very very strong
but you just have to be consistent so
that's important and it's also it's a
sense of it's for me a lot of it is
psychological as well you if i don't
train
like i don't feel right you need those
endorphins or
you know everyone's wired differently
and you need that sense of
growth that sense of you know physical
expression
some people need it some people don't i
need it i have to be
i have to train um so
yeah i don't want to keep this way
although i feel okay i could sprint and
stuff
but i'm just borderline if i go too much
then it's game over
so i need to bring it back down which
i'm gonna aim to do but at the moment
i'm just enjoying the the strength
aspect um you know
and hopefully it's functional strength
as well so that's very important
and that's what for muslims we should do
things with purpose like you know be
functional
yeah absolutely so in terms of mma
what's your kind of style
are you a ground guy are you stand up
are you both i mean
my body tends to lean towards striking
but i have to work the ground game you
know how it is
yeah yeah now well what you could do
is you could train your ground game to
the level where you could basically
neutralize
any kind of takedowns or neutralize
anything you don't have to be a master
on the ground
so my advice would be is master one
thing like i would always be scared of
someone who has
who has mastered for example the left
right
and he's done it for about 10 000 hours
rather than someone who's a little bit
good at everything because when someone
sharpened one tool
really really well then that person is
very dangerous like mcgregor take
mcgregor for example right
notwithstanding his personality issues
right
but that that left hand right
that is that's a bomb right if he
catches you with that it could be good
night
i don't care who you are i don't care if
you're the best grappler it catches you
you're finished right
and that's why people women could would
basically create a strategy in order to
prevent
facing that left hand um likewise
you know if someone's a really good
wrestler you have to create a strategy
that you could basically neutralize some
of his takedowns and neutralize some of
his attacks or his groundwork
in order for you to basically give you
the opportunity to focus on the
strengths that you have which is your
your striking game but nevertheless you
have to have both though because
you know if you don't know how to deal
with the groundwork it's finished
you're literally finished yeah yeah 100
but yeah so yeah i mean it's good what
about you guys anything you guys do in
terms of fitness failures
romney yeah i used to be more into like
strength training all that do more
calisthenics now
oh wow yeah that that's good
those guys and you know you know you
know the thing with with that type of
training and even strength training
even if you don't have any like kind of
martial skills
because you're going to be in the top 10
15
of your age group or your or your or
your kind of uh
group of people strength to a certain
degree
would outweigh skill and even fitness
like for example if you do kinesthetics
to the degree that you really really fit
and you do high intensity training
if you're able to be far more fitter and
run around someone who's
quite skillful the fit a guy can win
like for example if you have
two skilled guys that are the same but
one is fitter the third guy will always
win but i would also argue if you have
two skilled guys and one guy
has less skills but he's fitter the
fitter guy may win
yeah so and you see that a lot you know
because you may have the greatest skills
but if you can't last more than a half
one and a half minutes in the ring
what's the point yeah i used to i used
to wait i used to weigh 240 about two
years ago
and like completely like bulked up you
know strong
deadlifting benching but it's like bro
it's time for salah i'm huffing and
puffing
now i'm like 175 and it's like i feel
light on my feet
playing with little kids and stuff i
don't really feel tired right so
yeah yeah yeah i prefer this a little
more and and i could see how
myself looking you know as a father like
later in my life
this type of body type would be way
better than like just lifting heavy
stuff
yeah for sure absolutely and plus you
could be strong without gaining size
anyway
you just have to basically change your
training like if you look at the olympic
weightlifters some of them look quite
slim
but they're very powerful and they're
very strong
yeah and that's why in mma even in
boxing you incorporate
the power lifting aspects as well so you
know
the the snatch and and so on and so
forth
um and even deadlifts um
yeah so if you keep you could keep the
the the the key components of the weight
training
but you could incorporate in a
functional uh fitness
i mean my advice is not to do deadlifts
my advice would be to do the
what's that bar thing that goes around
you try the t-bar
the trap bar the trap bar yeah the
reason it's very good
because you're less likely to damage
your lower back and just
and for longevity you want to think
about 10 15 20 30 years in the future if
you want to keep on training and you
should
you know you should use exercises that
are less likely to just grind you and
mess you up
so you can get the same benefits with
the trap bar maybe not 100
the same you use a little bit more legs
but you still get your lower back and
your glutes and stuff and you get that
core
strength uh and that you know you get
that power from
the trap bar so i would advise everyone
to even invest in the trap bar because
deadlifts could
they could they could destroy you man
i can speak from experience you know the
uh stiff-legged deadlifts
yes oh yeah yeah oh
man like minion is that what it's called
like really like
you're just going down like this yeah
it's for hamstrings yeah
yeah yeah it's got good morning exercise
right oh no the good morning is when you
have it on your back and you're doing
that same thing
but um i was doing the stiff legged
deadlift in 2017
and i remember like i was lifting his
weight way too heavy
for no reason and um as i'm lifting it i
felt this like
kind of like pool in my back i was like
ah like what is this so i started
stretching it and then i went
right back to doing the exercise and
then like it just kept getting tighter i
was like yo what's going on
and then my uh
my my dumb self went over to the leg
press it was like alright well my back
is tight
let's hit some leg press then and then i
started going in on that
the leg press and then by the end of the
workout i was just stuck like this
i couldn't even get i was like oh yeah
something happened
and to this day i still feel it in my
lower back if i'm not careful so
you speak yeah yeah yeah yeah so
you need to think about longevity you
think about
um all of those things it's very
important because you know having a
short
term mindset on these issues it could
really really
really damage you like really damage you
i remember my elbows were on fire
when i was trying to do i think i was
doing boxing training and i was
like doing like weight training as well
literally
my elbows were on fire like the
tendonitis i had was just crazy and i'm
the kind of guy that would train around
it
like rest there's something
psychological about not training i'll be
like oh no it's fine i'll try and train
around it it'll just make it worse
and that's because it's all a sense of
overtraining or not not being wise
so you need to use the right exercises
for for your longevity you know
uh what about romney what do you do do
you do you play basketball
do you what do you do he knew it bro
yeah i used to play basketball a lot
going on oh really
um more recently i've been just trying
to put on weight um
weightlifting all that the gym is closed
so i switched like calisthenics and
stuff at home
um but yeah that's really good you know
like when the gyms closed as well i had
bands
and band training is actually really
good so you could get this
not exactly the same in my experience
but you could get similar
growth and similar strengths if you
train with bands
but to uh to failure what i mean by
bands is like
the proper heavy duty bands yeah yeah
yeah and you know you could do
back you could do uh chest you could do
legs you could do everything and it you
get the pump you get a better pump as
well i believe right
yeah so uh yeah bags helped me just
maintain
um so you know you should never have an
excuse and that's why i always say
discipline
is more important than motivation i know
a lot of people say this as well
because motivation will go up and down
but you have a vision for yourself
and then you you set a plan of action
you're disciplined with that
you're more likely to be successful
because discipline trumps
um motivation any day and you know
you're just pulling yourself out of bed
and
just doing it and that's why even with
fajr right when people have difficulty
praying fajr
it's just about being disciplined it's
just getting yourself up right
and just doing it right um discipline is
extremely important for most things in
life to be honest
and discipline is linked to someone and
i think it was ibrahim
you know may allah the basis for all of
is sabbah right you know and that's why
patience is so important because that is
one of the necessary
aspects of you to be disciplined you
need to be patient because discipline is
actually working hard over a long period
of time
in order to reach your goal and your
vision and it's going to be i remember i
had to train
twice i was doing this camp and had to
train twice a day
sometimes and you know you train in the
morning
and you go pull yourself out in the
evening and you i'm talking about
you know you you work the whole day and
you've got family and then you still got
to basically go and drink in the evening
it's a nightmare or even train on your
own right
um so discipline is always going to make
you
reach your goals and that's why i think
to everyone listening i know we've been
talking about
our conversation our conversation has
been a bit more relaxed but
um what people need to have a vision for
themselves
you know what does the vision mean it
basically means
where do i want to see myself right
so where do i see myself in 10 years 20
years 30 years
so what do you look like now your vision
can change over time as you mature no
problem but you should have a vision
where because some and the thing about
people your age or even even my age
still
people don't have a vision for
themselves so you should have a vision
about
you know obviously we all want to go
paradise for sure yeah we want to be
good muslims but that's too generic
you know have a vision what what do you
want to look like physically
spiritually intellectually and socially
in the next 10 years write it down
once you have a vision for yourself then
choose at least three or five or
certain limited actions or strategies
that you're going to adopt
that are that are necessarily linked to
your vision meaning if you do them
you're more likely to achieve your
vision
brainstorm that look at successful
people do sure speak to people around
you speak to scholars whatever
how do i get this done and then after
have
daily actions that i linked to those
strategies right
i'll give an example if someone wants to
be a person of zika right
you want to be the person that does the
morning and
evening they could every day
but you want to do it in a way that is
the decade of the tongue
and the heart you know in and now what
does he talk about
in i think in catabol when he talks
about you know the different types of
thicker
yes you could just utter it and not know
the meaning you still get reward
but you get more reward right or it has
more impact
if you're doing the thicker and you're
saying it relatively slowly and
you know the meaning and your heart is
attached to what you're saying like
in bulger for example you know the
prophet salallahu
said that you know it's it's the best
diker to do is
right is to do the um
alhamdulillah is to do uh the taqb right
so these things are very important so um
and and if you were to do that and know
the meaning of
for example to know the meaning of
to know the meaning of subhanallah to
know the meaning
of um
yeah so if your heart is attached to
when you're seeing it
you're present with it it's going to
have a great impact right everything has
a polish
and the polish of the of the heart is
the thicker of allah
so the point is i say you want to be a
person of morning
of morning amen you want that consistent
i want to be a person of zika
and so that means you have your evening
and your morning vicar and your duas so
the way to do that
is to say right in let's say this is a
small vision i want to
be able to do this consistently in the
next three months so in three months i
see myself as someone who is a person of
zika
always consistently doing the morning
and evening so now you've got to think
about certain actions that you need to
do
daily in order for that to happen well
some of the actions include will first
and foremost memorize your dikka
or if you can't do that's a bit of a
jump just select
the more closer to what you what you
what you align yourself with collect the
duals that
the the initial that you maybe
appreciate more
so say it's three thicker said subhan
allah will be hamdihi 100
in the morning in the evening and then
you pick something else and then you
you keep those three then you have right
you you pick these two duas
all right say you say uh this
uh which
would be islam would be muhammad
you say that three times in the morning
evening um and that has its benefits as
well so
um you pick two duas the tree of god and
then you you start
doing them so you do that for the first
week
the next phase would be right let me
learn the meanings of the individual
words of
these afghar and these duas so then you
learn the meaning
and then you say them with the meaning
in mind and you deal with a sense of
presence right
so when you've done that then you try
and memorize them and then you will
because after a
few days or weeks you'll memorize them
very easily then that's part of your
routine now morning and evening
and then you put you create an
environment that facilitates
your vision in the context of thicker so
maybe you'll have your thicker book
always next to you
before you go to bed so it's part of
your environment or
you have it on your office table you
have different copies in different
places
so it's always reminding this part of
your environment
to remind you or you put reminders on
your phones you create an environment
for yourself
to in order for you to do the vikar and
the duas once you've done that then you
could add now
the other afghan to do right then you
could add more duas to do
when you reach to a certain level where
now you're
trying to fulfill the complete sunnah of
the morning in the evening
and you could do that over the next few
weeks and months and then by
the third month you've got it all under
your belt now
you and it's all about being consistent
and obviously while you're doing that
you
praise allah and you thank allah and you
make dua to allah to make easy for you
to do this because it's only going to
happen because of allah
so i know this is a very small example
but everyone should have a vision for
themselves
and and that should include spiritual
physical social and otherwise
and that should always be you should
always remind yourself about where you
want to go where
what you want to be or or what does
hamza look like in the next 10 to 15
years
and then you go create a strategy or a
set of strategies in order
for that vision to materialize which
would which would affect your daily
actions every day
so when it comes to you brothers or
anything when it comes to fitness
spirituality and stuff
just have a vision for yourself and that
vision may change over time there's
nothing wrong with that
but have a vision and then have a
strategy to make that vision happen
and then links daily actions that are
part of that strategy for that vision to
materialize
i don't know how we got to this but i
think it's important i mean
with that being said what is your
current personal routine right
i want now be very honest with you uh
and hopefully i've tried to be authentic
in these podcasts
you know authenticity is one of the
missing things in social media
yeah is that guy real that guy is not
real does he always speak like that
like you know i know sometimes when you
see people obviously you must have an
other break
you know the famous statement of
suffering when he said you know
i'm not like i am with my buddies kind
of thing with the umber because they'll
just think that you know islam they
won't take islam seriously so i do agree
but in the age of social media there is
a certain context where
we need to revive a sense of
authenticity because when someone's
authentic
there's something loving about that
person there's something like you know i
want to know more about them i want to
take them more seriously because they're
coming across
as genuine and authentic you know it's
not just
a drama or a show yeah so to be very
authentic with you and hopefully i won't
regret this you know
um i've been absolutely lacking the for
the past
few weeks maybe yeah a few weeks i need
to get back and
i need to get back i need to get back on
track when it comes to routine
but i know what i need to do that's the
thing so the good thing about having
this discipline and vision
i know what needs to happen and i just
need to recalibrate and decompress
so it was it was a crazy period
especially in ramadan
um because of you know getting a new
project like sapience
and making sure we had to be in a
certain position and get work done and
trying to
manage everybody and trying to create
you know essentially create a new
organization
uh that is that basically absorbed
actually this is an excuse forget that
man that's it
but lie is an excuse yeah i'm just
listening so what kind of subtle excuse
is this
actually excuse me i've literally failed
for the past few weeks though and i'm
gonna
sort myself out thank you for inviting
me
hey you reminded yourself you reminded
yourself i i need to i need to uh
i need to uh get back on track in terms
of like the morning routine so the ideal
morning routine would be
you know wake up in the morning
obviously pray your fajr ideally must be
in the masjid you should do in the
masjid
doing your [ __ ] in the morning going
to the gym i think morning
workouts are something different like
you've you've achieved something
especially with a tough one and you've
got the whole day in front of you so
that's very important
obviously your whole day should be
revolved around salah obviously with the
work that we do that's relatively easy
because we don't have other kind of
things that you know other
things that's going to affect that um
and then after
you have to do your daily actions that
link to your vision so for example
you know at the moment i have to finish
a dissertation that is going to
um have to give in on the first of
september
so my daily actions will be i have to
at least write maybe 800 words a day
about 800
good words researched words a day for
example yeah
so that would be part of my uh daily
practice
um in terms of just work wise or
academia-wise
then you have other things that for
example you know if you're in a
leadership position
then true leadership in my view is
leading from the front and leading from
the behind
and also empowering and developing your
people so you should be committed to the
well-being of your people so you need to
make sure that you have a plan your own
plan of action for the people that
you're supposed to be managing
to get the best out of them and to
create get the best version of them
right because a lot of people
you'd be so surprised what a little bit
of encouragement does to a human being
and people sometimes need that even if
they're already successful you could
unveil blind spots in them in order to
see things that you see
get get them to see things that you see
and like yes i can achieve this
because the whole art of that type of
leadership is to seeing people what they
can't see in themselves
and get them to see that and get them to
move forward and realize that you know
so you know part of your daily actions
were to be to help your people
obviously you have your family daily
actions as well what you need to do with
the children and so on and so forth
because you you'll have visions for your
children as well right
and then you'll have to do daily actions
that link to their to the vision that
you have for your children that you want
your children to be pious you want them
to be
you know able to deal with life's
problems in the most effective way and
so on and so forth
so yeah i mean at the moment it's a bit
of a transitionary period
i'm gonna fix up but yeah there's me
being vulnerable
so you would say that your vision that
in the next five to ten years you see
hamza
diesel for his wife for the sake of
allah of course
and just putting in work and being able
to spread the dawah even more
yes so that's actually a good question i
think i'm in a stage in my life at the
moment i need to
review my vision uh but that
should happen very soon and i think what
it's going to involve in
it what it's going to involve is
obviously a vision for
the daoa but not maybe myself
necessarily but for the people that
i'm trying to help manage and develop in
order for them
to become better versions of themselves
and for them to help
manage and develop other people because
true leadership is
creating other leaders right in in a
certain sense especially in the content
of the daoa
because this whole kind of celebrity
kind of dawa is not
not the most effective right we need to
basically
create other leaders and leadership
doesn't mean always being on social
media always being very loud or always
being you know
um you know in the public line like
leadership has different dimensions so
creating
leaders in order to create effective
change for the sake of allah wa to add
us it's definitely going to involve
something like that
um obviously from a personal point of
view definitely
reviving the quran as a central focus in
my life especially from the point of
view of
meaning and understanding the quran and
taking that journey a little bit more
seriously
much more seriously um because you know
you get to realize after all of this
philosophy and all of this stuff then
you always come back to the quran the
quran's arguments the best arguments the
quran's narratives are the best
narratives the quran's values are the
best values they come from allah
so being connected to the quran and and
actually sharing that message with
others and
and all your work being contingent on
the quran
in terms of referring to it contest
consistently in a way that people can
understand
that that definitely is going to be a
personal vision of mine as well
inshallah but also because i'm a father
um spare with me i'm just going to put
the charger in yeah one second
[Music]
because i'm using my phone
so the way to charge this is to
basically
uh put it onto the laptop yes so um
the you know i really have to uh
start thinking more now seriously about
the vision for the family as a whole as
well
obviously that was already there to a
certain degree but
now you know as i said your vision
changes as you develop
and it can change and you'll have to
adapt so
more at this age now more thinking about
the kids and
you know how how can we get the best out
of them how can we make them into like
the ideal muslim
and also for them to be able to learn
from the mistakes in a way that makes
them grow
and for them to be able to basically
have that kind of sense of self mastery
you know
from an islamic perspective that's very
important so that's going to be
something i'm going to be focusing on as
well um
and yeah so there's all this academic
vision there's a physical vision there's
a
relationships vision there's you know
i've learned recently maybe
in the past four or five years maybe
that
you know to love someone for example you
should love them the way they want to be
loved not the way you want to be loved
yeah and that you know sometimes
relationships fails because
you know say for example your love
language is gifts
and words of affirmation you know
just echoing the book the five love
languages yeah we should actually
correct the book
uh and you're and you like that so you
like gifts you think that's an
expression of love
and you also like um uh
words of affirmation i love you right
now
say your spouse their love language is
not gifts
and their love language is not words of
affirmation if you're basically gonna
start giving them gifts all the time
words of affirmation they're never going
to feel loved their love tank is not
going to be filled
you think you've been so loving but
really you're just like loving yourself
man in in maybe
maybe a narcissistic way because true
love is loving someone the way they want
to be loved
so you know maybe to focus on that much
more now as well
obviously hopefully i had it but you
know just to realize that with everybody
around not just your spouse and your
children but everyone around you know
what makes this person feel loved you
know because the person's son was
was someone who was uh a rahma to to the
whole worlds
and the way he related to people they
felt that they were like the center of
his universe or the most loved right you
know the famous
narrations um so you know
find out what how people how how can you
make someone feel
loved right and you know maybe
fayad's love languages um
gifts or maybe it's words of affirmation
so when i connect with him i'm going to
connect with him in that way so his love
tank is filled right
but you know he he'll feel complete
you know when we when when we're
relating to each other other people
they don't they just like a bit they're
more like touched like touch
so a pat on the back or a hug or um
other people might like um quality time
to spending time with someone right
everyone's different they must go down
love languages so hey i don't know how
to get into that but yeah so
uh where do i see myself i i'm
i'm in the stage of redeveloping that
vision i think now yeah so let me just
turn the
question back to you guys so where do
you see yourself
let's start with the question of first
having so where do you see yourself in
10 years
i can barely see myself in a few months
from now i can't i can't even see in a
few days bro
yeah okay maybe maybe let's change the
question
if you might we're managing yourself
say someone came into the room and it
happened to be you
so you are outside of yourself but
you're managing yourself
and then that's your sole responsibility
and then that person says right i'm
going to be the best version of myself
in 10 years what does that look like
so you need to manage them you need to
take them then how are you going to take
you there
uh okay i got i got a few things i got a
few things
good bismillah i miss you now so
in terms of physical i want to
[Music]
at least be in peak performance
you know and i'm not just saying like oh
in the gym
in fighting i'm talking about like in
everything that i'm doing
so like if i got a if i gotta help
someone move
i can help the move without breaking a
sweat if i'm gotta walk like 10
15 20 miles i can walk 10 15 20 miles
without any issue you know no medical
issues no nothing
not taking any medication just on that
good
whole food provided by okay okay created
okay so that's that so how are you gonna
get that what do you think are the three
main
key actions to get to that
continuing training continuing eating
properly and
continue to do new training programs to
you know keep progressing okay so
what would be what would a week look
like now
exactly what i'm doing right now i'm
training like anywhere from
okay brilliant and then so then then you
say it says what does a day look
like right so you break it down like
that so that's the fitness so give me a
spiritual goal now
spiritual goal
i want to be able to be
more in tune with allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
because sometimes i have high mind
sometimes i have low iman and
when i have low iman i'm being honest
it's
it can be very difficult um i have adhd
so that's uh it makes my mental state be
all over the place whereas like you know
how you were saying you have to train in
order for you to like feel
feel good i have to train too if i don't
train
mentally i feel like i'm just off
like i'm in a haze you know so i just
i want to be able to have that real
focus and that real like really be in
tune with allah subhanahu wa
okay so that's that's my goal yeah so
you want to aim to get closer to the
subpanel allah okay
so what do you think what are the three
main things you need to do to achieve
that
that's it okay good so
you be a person of zikr so you start
learning your
morning and evening of god and you
become you be consistent
um quran right
yeah that could be a day read quran
every day these
20 minutes every twenty after five jesus
read it twenty minutes
even if you can't read the arabic read
the english ponder on the meanings
um also obviously we know about the
foreign
five deadly prayers etc um but
you know have subigatory actions as well
because the whole concept and obviously
this is advice to myself
the whole concept of the fog is like a
it's like a fortress around the heart
protecting the heart right
and then the sunnah is like a double
another fortress
and then the extra actions is like
another fortress protecting the heart
so when you remove some of the
supracatchy actions you move away the
the sunnah
and and then it will just your their
fortress is not that strong
right from a kind of heart perspective
so think about
daily practice something that you should
do every day that only you and allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala knows right
and that would preserve the class aspect
and it could be giving sadhaka every day
even if it's like a dulla
right or it could be you know doing an
extra
prayer like the um
the the fourth the prayer before the
noon right
um which was a very consistent prayer of
the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam or you know get up 10 minutes
before fajr time
once a week make that dua you know
in the last third of the night and just
cry to allah and beg
him to keep you strong and increase your
iman
and also try and throw in two rakats as
well as a target prayer yeah or
or malay so try and find some things
that
also your heart is more inclined towards
like some people are more inclined
towards zika rather than
uh the extra prayers like tahajjud for
example or some people are more inclined
to this than the other
obviously we should try and do
everything as much as possible but see
w what does your heart tell you um
but one thing as well is to get your
vision spiritually in tune
is to have right people around you uh
when you speak to the scholars of tasker
nufs
you know the spiritual disease of the
heart how to deal with them how to do
with iman
one of the key things their key thing is
companionship
it is so important you're you are the
product of the people around you yeah
and you know allah subhanahu wa tada
especially when it comes to youth
the people of the cave they were youth
right
and the dog happened to be with them
and allah saved the people of the cave
and
allah saved the dog so you could
question why does allah save the dog as
well why is the dog even mentioned
but there's a powerful story here
because allah is basically maybe telling
us
that if allah can save a lowly animal
like a dog because it happened to be
with pious people
imagine how allah will save you if you
happen to be with pious people
yeah so the power of your environment
to force yourself in good environments
that is
probably the basis of any spiritual
development is to force yourself in good
environments
so you do thicker you do your quran you
do your extra thing that thing that
that you own it could be uh maybe a
salah it could be the duas and the last
time in the night
it could be sadaqa it could be a
combination but just pick something that
you just own
and keep on being consistent with it it
could be
uh yeah so but but whatever you choose
you have to have good companionship
because you know even if you do all
these great things
unless you're a really really good
leader it's going to be so difficult for
you to stay on track
you have to be around good people you
have to be around good people
uh and that's very important for you to
have good people around you humber
you're good
in good company here with feyard and
rami alhamdulillah
so yeah so that so the exercise we're
doing now obviously it's not
complete it's not thorough but even this
kind of conversation
gets people to realize i need a vision
i need a vision for my life i need i
want to be
someone who is close to allah i want to
be someone who's physically fit and
healthy
i want to be someone who's a good leader
that inspires other people for the sake
of allah right how do i get there
what do i do so talk to people ask
people who already achieved that it's
called bright spotting
go to the bright stars of the um ask
them how do you how do you
how do you do this how do you learn to
speak like this how do you learn to lead
how do you know to be so humble how do
you whatever
speak to them find out what they do do
the bright spot
have good people around you um think
about this essential actions that would
lead
to your vision and then break it down on
a day-to-day
basis all these conversations and these
questions need to be raised and you need
we need to take it very seriously in
actual fact
you know maybe this kind of transitional
phase i'm in
just being on this podcast with you has
been one of the greatest
blessings i can ever imagine honestly if
only you knew
you knew it's actually now it's forcing
me now not
not to sound like a hypocrite and put
some of these things in action now right
because i'm thinking
what you've been doing for the past few
weeks or months you need to get back on
track man what's going on hunger right
so this has been such like i could never
think enough
i am eternally grateful for this
conversation
even me just like chilling on this chair
just talking to you in the
hopefully the most authentic way uh i
it's yeah yeah may allah make is for all
of us
but i think the lesson that everyone
should land and we should learn is
let's have a vision for ourselves um
i think as well he said those who are
suffer
from shubu hearts from destructive
doubts um they don't have a vision for
themselves they are people who run
vision for themselves
so we need a vision for our lives right
otherwise we're going to get affected by
the
superheart the destructive doubts and
there's you know the tsunami of atheism
and liberalism and
neo and neo this and neil that and
feminism and post-modernism and
all of these issues and schisms is alien
these alien ideological
constructs and narratives they're there
to
they're there as superheart to try and
attach to our hearts and drain our iman
and ibrahim made a really good point
saying
you don't have a vision for yourself if
you're going to get effective like that
from that perspective so we should have
vision for ourselves
protect our iman and and and develop
ourselves
and that's a sign of i think spiritual
and just maturity in general
you know where do you want to be where
do you want to be
and you can't do it in a bubble you may
have to help
you know your wife and your children and
your whole family
to be centered around your vision and
their vision as well it's all like bring
elevating everybody together because
we can't do it alone and that's we have
to have really really good company
really good people around you um but
yeah so i just want to thank you so much
for
for this uh for this opportunity because
even you just raising the question of me
attempting to be slightly authentic or
hopefully authentic enough to answer it
by saying
i mean this kind of limbo situation
has maybe awakened me up to take things
a little bit more seriously
and just to refocus again you know
hey guys well i am eternally grateful
i'm eternally grateful
but yeah but take it seriously too yeah
write down your vision
maybe i'll check up for you next week
see let's check up let's take each other
to account man
let's see if we we yeah let's do that
we've got each other whatsapp messages
let's say what you're doing with your
fitness vision with your spiritual
vision with your
relationship vision what's going on what
have you done what three main strategies
what what other actions you're doing on
a day-to-day basis
let's do that yeah let's take two each
other
you know any any bit of value that you
got from this any of the viewers
watching everything's from allah so
use that into account and just realize
that allah does love you
and do what you can every day to get
closer to him and not farther and not
stay stagnant because i'd rather go one
step forward than just stay the same
man bless you man i mean god bless you
guys
this episode has been it's been so real
allah i was just like sitting in and
thinking you know about my own my own
goals and everything and my conviction
in them and all that subhanallah
and it reminds me of something that my
um mentioned yesterday he said
when you look at the difference uh
between the person who's 99
uh sure they want to do something and
they give it 99
effort and conviction and take that
person compared to the person who's 100
sure they're going to do it and they
have 100 conviction the entire
neural chemistry is different the entire
brain scan is different
and just that little sliver of one
percent of not
fully being convicted 100 in what you're
doing
gives room to that procrastination that
excuse that
so on and so forth and as you mentioned
having yakin
is so important for everything we do in
life and that's why it's so important
for for muslims to be
convicted in la illah in islam in their
deen
and also what they're working towards
and be convicted in their goals
so i wanted to add that at the end
because subhanallah it's one thing to
make a goal
but some people they they struggle just
to start it and they struggle to
maintain it because they don't have that
that certainty that this is what i'm
going to do no matter what
well i struggle with that myself so
maybe we should do a follow-up podcast
in six months to see what's happened
since
that'll be epic yeah it's a good idea
inshallah it'll be uh
you know roundup for the year of 2021.
yeah that sounds good
[Laughter]
how about this before we wrap this up
then um let's all come
come up with three goals that we have so
in six months when we do
we can check in and we'll remember this
this is proof proof is in the pudding
because we're putting this out there
so i'll let uh brother rami go first
insha allah yeah that's why
um how specific does it have to be
it could be general it could be specific
it's up to you because you're you're
only accountable to yourself and allah
so i want you to watch this in six
months and be like okay
tick tick tick not somebody else and you
know
alhamdulillah i want to have a body
that's closer to the the body that i
want in terms of
muscle mass and everything i want to put
on some weight that's why i asked about
how specific you know 10 pounds 20
pounds so on and so forth
so i want to be closer inshallah that's
one goal second goal i want to increase
myself in my islamic knowledge um
and also you know and tuskey i humble
myself and you know i'm going to make it
to
two different goals one in my islamic
knowledge my application of that and
and secondly my the tesca aspect of it
humbling myself keeping the ego down
um and and just being the best person i
can be in my character and being closer
and more similar to the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam those are my
things
all right i like that all right bro
so one have be closer to the body i want
so right now i'm cutting so maybe
150 pounds all right uh so that's gonna
be one
number two uh memorize at least five
sodas that i don't know
right so this this has been a big goal
of mine i've been speaking to rami
a couple nights you know here and there
just yo how do i memorize
quran how do i at least start with
memorizing quran right i learned tejuri
at a young age you know reading
translations and all that
but not being you know a native arabic
speaker you know it's something it's a
goal of mine
and to spread you know islam into dawah
you must
understand islam to understand islam you
must you know
know the quran so that's one goal that i
have so i'll be two
number three um honestly man two is two
is big for me right now
but number three i would just say
make position my business because i do
online coaching right so fitness and all
that
so position it in a way where i'm making
the standard that i had for myself set
for this year right so i had that set
for the end of the year
so i'm the other way worked out in the
conversation six months from now it'll
be at the end of the year so just reach
that goal
um help you know through the grace of
allah transform
hundreds of lives that's it bro
hamza you want to go first you want me
to go oh
it's up to you bro if it depends if you
want age to go before beauty
ah nah if beauty goes first
go ahead bro no it'll be you then that
would be you i'm i'm actually 42 years
old
what no you're not
i'm i'm 40 i'm not gonna be 41 in
september inshallah
how old does he look though if you
didn't know he's uh he's 19.
honestly the the grace in your beard
lets me know that you're like
later 30s but if if that was like fully
black
that's not great bro it's not just the
skin yeah it was the skin yeah
ah okay well then but to me that's how
it looked like but if i see you in
person and i would have seen that was a
skin
i'd say like maybe thirty one thirty two
thirty one max
yeah uh brother how old would you think
angel is if you didn't know he was 19
years old
uh you know it's very hard to tell on
zoom to be honest
and you know the thing with age it's so
it's like
what does what does a third year look
like these days like i've seen 38 year
olds they look 50 and i've seen some
three eight-year-olds look
25 or something maybe or you know
something like that
so you don't you're definitely young
you're definitely in your 20s right
yeah i'm playing he's not 19 but but you
are definitely in your 20s that's for
sure yeah yeah
yeah rami was 19 when we started the
podcast
you guys are all young that's for sure
it doesn't mean you're maybe
someone you could read 21 25 26 yeah
so from the 21 to 26 region yeah
mashallah bless you guys so uh yeah so
beauty first go for it bro
all right i'm just gonna bro so
if i had to choose three things in six
months number one
is i wanna fully be able to
go spear fishing uh this past weekend i
was learning how to free dive
you know what free diving is uh is it
basically just
no i don't actually go and tell me it's
it's just diving underwater but like
with no scuba tank or anything and
some people stay underwater yeah some
people can stay underwater for like 10
12 minutes at a time and um i want to be
able to
perfect that so that i can go into the
water with a spear gun
and basically hunt my own food
i think that would be just the most
i don't know just a different experience
to be able to do that number two
i would love to be back at it into
mma i've recently before ramadan i took
a break from mma because i had a groin
injury
and i'm like you i'm like oh i'm just
gonna train around i'm gonna train
around it
i did that for like six months and it
the injury just got really bad to work
at barely walk
yeah so um insha allah
insha allah will be healed and i will be
doing mma again and then the
third goal that i have that i'm going to
be sitting here is i'm gonna make it a
priority
to be spending at least minimum
15 minutes after prayer
each prayer to just sit down
and self-reflect and just be with allah
subhanahu wa
in that time because i feel like
sometimes i'll hit the prayer
and like i'll just be like oh i gotta do
this and i'll finish the prayer and then
like go off and like start doing things
again
and i just feel like that just adds to
like a lack
of presence a lack of mindfulness and
i don't know it's kind of disrespectful
it's like oh well let me get this over
with instead of like well let me
actually worship my creator you know
so those are my three videos i just want
to say one thing that uh
i was i was ex i was extending my
gratitude
gratitude towards uh you know brother
hamza to sheikh abu alia
right when we had him on and we were
telling him you know like
man you know i had a huge role
you know alhamdulillah through you know
me getting on dean and all that and i
was telling him all that he's like
bro you're saying this before you even
like met him like spoken to him
you're saying that's just seeing his
videos wait till you see him in person
he's like the real deal i was like
is a very very special human being
honestly very special human being
he's right man he's right because i
honestly lost track that we've been
talking for three hours right now
no and i remember you know shaykh abu
ali and allah preserve him i've actually
because i lost my phone i lost my sim so
a lot of the contacts i've i need to get
his number again hopefully it's
somewhere hidden in the whatsapp i'll
just message you on whatsapp after we're
done
yeah yeah so he's the one who revived
the kind of understanding
of the kind of the full spiritual
disease of the heart and how to deal
with them
and so he's been a huge inspiration
which really
is one of the most important things we
should be talking about in our current
age because a lot of our actions
are a derivative of our state of heart
and even if you do the right action but
you stay at heart is not correct and
there will be no barakah there will be
no true success from that perspective
so yeah so you know
maybe he was being a bit charitable
about who i am but he
is uh he's very very special human being
and i'll bless him and
he needs to be promoted more absolutely
because the stuff that he has
is is extremely enriching for everybody
so may not preserve him and grant him
and his family the best in this life and
the best
in the life to come but um
in terms of your salah thing but what's
really powerful is
uh what one can do in order to create
that presence maybe
is to lengthen the shrood
right lengthen the sajdah
and just maybe be more uh take the pre
be take more time in the prayer the way
to do that
is to start with because it's got to say
that
your prayer starts at will do time you
know we'll do it like
you know really fast i think i knew one
guy he could do would do in like 25
seconds or something or 30 seconds
which i think is really fast yeah um do
we do and also look what's the inner
dimensions of
you know the pressure said that when
you're doing will do like your sins are
being washed away so just know that's
the fact
your sins are being washed away you are
preparing for one of the greatest acts
of worship which is salaat
and then when you finish you will do and
you do it properly uh
with its own with this with with this
due right or
you know in the right way then you go
into salah and then
when you go into salah obviously because
we did it five times a day
it becomes very mechanistic so what we
need to try and figure out
is being the state of mind or presence
from the wudu to understand what i'm
what i'm doing in the first place i'm
here i'm worshiping allah i'm fulfilling
an obligation i am glorifying allah and
try and learn everything that you say in
arabic in the prayer
understand it the meaning and also
develop a sense of a sense of humility
and heartbrokenness
and an o of allah in
the different stages of the salah when
you're standing when you in sajdah when
you understand what these means you're
buying to the lord of the heavens and
the earth to the king of all kings
you're putting your face onto the onto
the floor and to the ground which is
like
you know the face is the symbol of the
ego that you're really nothing in
reality
you know when you peel away all of your
kind of identities like even the fact
what your name is and where you came
from and
your job and your titles and you remove
all of that stuff what's left really
really what are you you just you're just
an abbot you're just a worship of allah
yeah
and it's through that humility allah
will elevate you so
get into the kind of what you call the
inner dimensions of the salah and get an
appreciation and the feeling of that
in your salah um and because sometimes
you can become mechanistic you know
allah about
no you know even the concept allahu
akbar allah is greater
not the greatest allah is greater than
anything you can imagine
anything in the universe allah is great
even the very fact that we say allahu
akbar we should internalize within
ourselves
that you know allah is worthy of the
greatest extensive praise you can
imagine because if you could praise like
martial artists and poets and thinkers
because of their attributes whether it's
writing whether it's
athleticism whatever the case may be if
we could praise them
by virtue of their attributes and their
attributes are diminished and flawed in
some way they're limited in some way
then what is what what does it mean how
we must praise allah
whose names and attributes are perfect
and
you know maximally perfect to the
highest degree possible so it means we
should give about the greatest extensive
praise right you know we could
praise the the mind of a scientist what
about the one who created that mind
we could praise you know an athlete
for his strengths and ability what about
the one who created that athlete right
he allah is deserving of greater
extensive praise because of who he is
right
so you know allahu akbar allah is great
imagine internalizing all of that
just when we say allahu akbar i know
that's hard
but you should have a program to try and
develop that in your salah over time
yeah and obviously there's going to be
peaks and troughs sometimes you get busy
sometimes this happens so
sometimes this is going to be a bit
faster we may not be in the right state
of mind or state of being
but always have in your mind that i want
to i want to be present with allah
subhanallah
ta'ala so i'm going to lengthen my salah
a little bit more
lengthening the sajdah a little bit more
be a little bit more focused in each
position and understand what
it what it what it really means and the
impact it should have on me
and understand everything that i'm
saying in the salah from surah
all the way to the duas that you make
and so on and so forth
once you start developing that slowly
over time your whole salah will change
and even you know making dua to allah
and sajdah the prophet sasan said that
the closest you are to your lord is
insatiable so supplicate to him
you know some people make dua straight
away after salah right i i'm not gunning
that
but it's equivalent in some way of
hanging up the phone on allah and then
just sending him a text
right because the closest you are is in
sajdah right so you know
suffocate told us subhanallah and i do
appreciate there is difference opinion
in the math
uh you know whether you can do in
english in in
in the sajdah or if it's specific arabic
to ours or even if you could make
duas in your farad prayers so i know
there is
so i'm not claiming to say that there is
one position here or anything but the
point is in general
you know subtle to allah you're closest
to your lord
in that state so so yeah
but yeah it's beautiful man bless you
guys right here oh it's my turn
uh i was like
until next time six months yeah you know
look to be very authentic it does
require more thought but this is my
intuitive
kind of um intuitive thing so the first
thing i want to do is i want to keep
every single
goal and commitment that we said to
people in ramadan what sapience
institute institute's gonna achieve
so we said things like we're gonna have
four academic debates
uh we're gonna have over 60 videos uh
we're going to have
uh uh publish i think three books
we're going to have we're going to train
and develop over 10 000 people
we're going to have 10 new professional
courses on our learning platform for
free
and other things so these are quite big
goals we're gonna have a book on doubts
right
dealing with doubts all the main doubts
you find online
and also strategies on how to deal with
doubts so you know
all of this has to happen by ramadan
so within the next six months or so i'm
going to try my utmost best insha'allah
with the will and help of allah
to get the team motivated and inspired
to achieve all of those goals
that's the first one the second one
thing the second thing is is to do a
deeper study of the book of allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
to go through the whole of the quran
from a
taser perspective multiple tafseers but
also to do right
i think that's very important and you
know i used to have a
quran i used to always highlight things
that jumped at me
jumped at me and the whole thing was
highlighted almost right
and in that process it helped me a lot
with tadab because
allah subhanahu wa says that do they not
reflect upon the quran or the locks on
their hearts
so you can mirror the meaning that the
more double you do the more your heart
becomes
unlocked to receive his guidance and
mercy right
so i want to do that right in the next
six months
because it just has to happen the odds
have to be connected to the quran not in
the superficial way but in a much deeper
way as well yeah
not only but also pondering because it
is
through a lot of pondering that you get
a lot of answers and even when i wrote
my book some of the stuff
with regards to some arguments or
enhancing some positions
uh was based on just reflecting on the
quran but
i you know i'm at a stage definitely has
to be far more deeper
and far more focused right and obviously
i can't do that myself so that means i
have to be connected with
specialists connected with because you
know people are not connected with the
scholar
scholars or students of knowledge those
people are very dangerous people
because there's no one around them to
basically keep them in check and make
sure
um that they're doing what they should
be doing and they are who they should be
so i have to connect with those guys
that's the second one
um the third one intuitively what comes
to my mind is
um yeah memorization of the quran
that is probably if anything has been my
greatest weakness as someone who
calls people to allah definitely
definitely memorize good chunks of the
quran
and keep that as a spiritual practice
continuously not just oh i'm gonna learn
this for now use it in the dao
or whatever or i'm gonna try and learn
it just for myself
um you know do it for for for for lofty
goals that you're glorifying allah you
want
light in your heart because the quran is
like a light right and also you want to
do it so it enriches your dollar and it
helps other people as well so
memorization so those three things
fulfill all the goals that we we said
we're going to achieve last ramadan
for this year up to next ramadan and
inspire
touch move and inspire the team to
achieve that the
the second thing was do a thorough study
of the book of allah
multiple series but also and be
connected with the people to facilitate
that process
and the third one was the memorization
of the book of allah so yeah
let's just keep each other in check when
it comes to that
let's do that
all right and everybody at home as well
set goals for yourself now so when that
episode comes out you can hold yourself
accountable and if you feel comfortable
then comment down your goals your three
goals for the rest of 2021
i'll like all the comments respond to
them and we'll keep each other
accountable guys we're all one big omaha
one big family
it's the least we could do
you've been uh inspirational um
apologies for maybe
more of a laid-back hamza um
it's just survived with our podcast
we don't like electric stuff i'm only
saying that if your expectations were
something else so
but this is me this is uh that showed up
conversational mode
may love bless you guys you've probably
brought the best out of me to be honest
so and it's been it's been very
transformative
so it's uh been that much needed kick
that i needed to be honest
just asking her for that yeah likewise
the discussions we've had were honestly
uh life-changing
uh and that's that's that's me you know
saying as an
that's an understatement frankly
subhanallah um like inshallah i'm gonna
watch them back and
and and reflect on it even more as he
said uh
is is really important so happy may
allah
any final words from the brothers i
don't know
just we appreciate you we appreciate
everything that you do for the woman
yeah make doll for us we've made many
mistakes so
there's lots of turban that needs to be
done and inshallah may allah accept even
the small things that we do
and all we need really all we need is
the mercy of this is the mercy of allah
all the time
so let's make ourselves eligible for
allah's mercy and may
bless you guys keep up the great work
and um
yeah and stay who you are because it's
great
i'm actually going to be watching your
other episodes now because
i don't think i've ever seen an episode
of your podcast before so i'm just going
to check them out
i'm going to check out chef abba aliyah
because he's always got he always has
something amazing to say
and transformative and and very
insightful
lots of basira from him you know deep
profound wisdom
from the shaykh when i preserve him and
also check him out as well
all right subscribe
there was a guy who asked he was an
atheist by the way how are you going to
feel if
you die and you find out that you know
there's no day of judgment there's no
heaven and how are you going to feel
and the chef answered i'm not going to
feel as bad as you would when you find
out there is
and at the end of the day i'm not saying
religion is fear-mongering islam is
fear-mongering but if you don't want to
have fear
of a love your creator and you want to
be logically sold on religion there's a
lot of intellectuals hamza zortzis
muhammad hijab
there's too many people subor ahmed too
many great scholars too many great
advocates of the truth too many great
cosmologists too many great physicists
too many great
even students of knowledge like rami
that are just out here doing
their due diligence open your eyes and
insha allah god willing
you are guided to see the truth but
allah does not change the condition of a
person until they change what's within
themselves
so if you guys don't change what's
within you you're not going to get an
allah's guidance
you're not going to get that yeah
[Music]
[Music]
um um